>> Sean: JUST HOURS BEFORE,
FOR INTEL CHAIRMAN COMMUNITY
DEVIN NUNES FILED A $250 MILLION
LAWSUIT AGAINST TWITTER IN
VIRGINIA STATE COURT, ALLEGING
THE SOCIAL MEDIA COMPANY
NEGLIGENTLY FAILED TO REMOVE
DEFAMATORY AND MALICIOUS TWEETS
ABOUT THE CONGRESSMAN AND HIS
FAMILY PER TWITTER IS DECLINING
COME IN TONIGHT, BUT HERE TO
TALK ABOUT THIS LAWSUIT AND MUCH
MORE.
CONGRESSMAN DEVIN NUNES.
YOU DO HAVE A HIGH BAR.
WE ALL NEED THAT.
IF YOU ARE A PUBLIC FIGURE, YOU
NEED ACTUAL MALICE AND WHAT'S
KNOWN AS A RECKLESS DISREGARD
FOR THE TRUTH.
OR ELSE I WOULD SUE PEOPLE EVERY
HOUR OF EVERY DAY.
BUT IT'S HARDER.
IT'S NOT LIKE IN THE CASE OF THE
COMMENTING HIGH SCHOOL KID.
TELL US ABOUT THE SUIT.
>> THIS IS THE FIRST OF MANY,
SEAN, WE ARE ACTUALLY GOING
AFTER TWITTER FIRST BECAUSE THEY
ARE THE MAIN PROLIFERATOR AND
THEY SPREAD FAKE NEWS AND
SLANDEROUS NEWS.
PEOPLE CAN LOOK ON FOX NEWS,
IT'S ALL THERE.
THE CASE WE WERE BASICALLY
LOOKING IS THIS IS AN
ORCHESTRATED EFFORT.
SO PEOPLE WERE TARGETING ME,
ANONYMOUS ACCOUNTS THAT WERE
DEVELOPED.
LOOK, THERE ARE -- THESE
ACCOUNTS AREN'T SUPPOSED TO
EXIST PRETWITTER SAYS THEY DON'T
HAVE ACCOUNTS THAT DO THIS.
THIS IS THE FIRST OF MANY
LAWSUITS THAT ARE COMING.
BUT THERE WERE SEVERAL FAKE NEWS
ACCOUNTS, WHETHER ITS REGARDS TO
THE RUSSIAN INVESTIGATION OR TO
ME, AND WE HAVE TO HOLD ALL OF
THESE PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE.
BECAUSE IF WE DON'T, OUR
FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHTS ARE AT
STAKE HERE.
THIS ISN'T 20 YEARS AGO, SEAN.
WHAT'S HAPPENING IS THAT TWITTER
BECOMES THE GAS LIGHTING FOR ALL
THE NEWS.
WHEN THEY ARE REGULATING US,
THEY'RE REGULATING WHAT PEOPLE
CAN SEE ON MY TWEETS, WHICH THEY
HAVE DONE, AND THEY ARE
PROLIFERATING OUT THINGS THAT
THEY AGREE WITH WITH THE
ALGORITHMS THAT THEY DEVELOP,
THEY NEED TO COME CLEAN.
THEY ARE A CONTENT DEVELOPER.
THAT'S RIGHT.
IF YOU REMEMBER LAST SUMMER,
THEY SHADOW BANNED ME.
>> Sean: HE DENIED THAT EVER
WENT ON, AND HE SAID HE WANTS TO
BE FAIR.
BUT YOUR ANALYSIS HAS NOT SHOWN
THAT IT IS FAIR ACROSS THE BOARD
AND THAT A LOT OF THESE
SOCIAL MEDIA SITES ARE IN FACT
USING THOSE ALGORITHMS, IF YOU
ARE WELL, OR THEY HAVE BEHAVIORS
TO ADVANCE ONE SIDE, WHICH WOULD
THEN BE, WHAT, A POLITICAL
DONATION FOR DEMOCRATS?
>> WELL, HOW IS IT THAT EVERY
DAY THERE'S CONSERVATIVES THAT
ARE BEING BANNED?
LOOK, THEY DON'T WANT TO COLLEGE
HAD A BANNING, THAT'S FINE.
THEY CAN CALL IT WHATEVER THEY
WANT TO CALL IT.
THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS PEOPLE
CANNOT SEE MY TWEETS.
IF YOU GET EMAILS FROM TWITTER,
IT'S COMMONLY FAKE NEW STUFF.
IF THEY DON'T WANT TO BE A
CONTENT DEVELOPER CAN MAKE US
ALL YOUR ALGORITHMS.
HOW IS IT POSSIBLE I CAN BE
ATTACKED RELENTLESSLY HUNDREDS
OF TIMES A DAY BY FAKE ACCOUNTS
THAT THEY CLAIM THEIR TERMS OF
SERVICE SHOULD NOT BE THERE.
I CAN PUT SOMETHING THAT'S
SEXUALLY EXPLICIT, ATTACKED
SOMEONE, THEY WOULD SAY STOP IT,
THIS IS A SENSITIVE TWEED.
THEY WOULD NEVER SAY THAT TO
PEOPLE COMING AFTER ME OR OTHER
CONSERVATIVES.
THIS IS MORE THAN JUST
EVERY AMERICAN SHOULD CARE ABOUT
THAT IF THEY SHOULD CARE ABOUT
THE FIRST AMENDMENT.
THE PRICE HAS CHANGED, YOU SAID
IT NUMEROUS TIMES FOR THE
PRESS IS DEAD.
IF WE DO NOT CLEAN THIS UP, I'VE
SAID THIS ON YOUR SHOW A FEW
WEEKS AGO.
THIS IS PART OF THE CONTINUING
RUSSIAN INVESTIGATION.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO LET THIS
DELL MAKE THESE FAKE NEWS STORIS
DELL MAKE THESE FAKE NEWS STORI,
WRITTEN ABOUT THIS INVESTIGATION
WRITTEN ABOUT THIS INVESTIGATIO,
WRITTEN ABOUT THIS INVESTIGATIOW
WRITTEN ABOUT THIS INVESTIGATIOE
ARE GOING TO CHALLENGE EVERY
SINGLE ONE IN COURT.
>> Sean: THE THING IS IT SO
INFLUENTIAL.
TALK ABOUT SO MANY, IF NOT
MILLIONS AND BILLIONS OF PEOPLE.
FACEBOOK AND SOME OTHERS.
IT'S INCALCULABLE HOW MUCH THAT
ASSISTS A NARRATIVE OR POINT OF
VIEW.
LET ME ASK YOU THIS.
AS THE FORMER HOUSE INTEL
COMMITTEE CHAIR, IT'S BEEN
FRUSTRATING AT SOMEBODY WHO'S
BEEN TRYING TO GET TO THE BOTTOM
OF THIS WHOLE HILLARY GETTING A
PASS, FISA ABUSE, BLUDGEONING
HIM WITH FALSE RUSSIAN LIES, NOW
THAT WE'VE HAD ORR, PAGE,
STROZK, THE McCAIN AIDE,
CHRISTOPHER STEELE, EVERYONE WAS
WARNED IN AUGUST LONG BEFORE
THEY LEAKED THIS INFORMATION
KNOWINGLY TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
AND USED IT AS, TO QUOTE YOUR
MEMO, THE BULK OF INFORMATION IN
THE FISA APPLICATIONS, HOW MUCH
MORE IS COMING?
I WAS TOLD THIS IS THE BEGINNING
OF AN AVALANCHE OF INFORMATION
THAT HAS BEEN HARD TO GET OUT,
BUT IT'S NOW COMING?
>> IT SLOWLY COMING.
SO THIS IS ALL IN THE RESULT OF
A TASK FORCE WE SET UP LAST YEA
YEAR.
WE HAVE SENT OVER 50 NAMES TO
THE NEW CHAIRMAN OF THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE THAT WE'D
LIKE TO INTERVIEW TO CONTINUE
THIS INVESTIGATION.
THERE IS ALSO THE INFORMATION
THAT IS STILL CLASSIFIED THAT WE
WOULD LIKE TO DECLASSIFY AND
THAT'S PRIMARILY 20 PAGES OF THE
LAST FISA, THE REPORT THAT BRUCE
OHR WAS INVOLVED IN.
AS YOU KNOW, BRUCE OHR IS A
CENTRAL FIGURE JUST LIKE ANDY
McCABE.
>> Sean: THE HALL CLINTON
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR RUSSIAN
DOSSIER LIES, WE KNEW THAT
BEFORE THE ELECTION THAT IT'S
ALL NOT TRUE.
AND STEELE SAID IT HIMSELF.
>> WHY IT'S SO IMPORTANT, PART
OF THE REASON I'M STARTING WITH
TWITTER AND THESE LAWSUITS AND
GOING ONTO THE FAKE NEWS
STORIES, IT'S IMPORTANT TO KNOW
WHO'S BEHIND PUTTING UP THOSE
FAKE NEWS STORIES.
>> Sean: WOW.
WE ARE GOING TO FOLLOW THIS VERY
CLOSELY.